good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-2030 object
class Keter special containment
procedures foundation operated web
analysis bot delta-9 laugh stop is to be
kept in constant operation and checked
for defects twice a week by a level two
staff member familiar with its operation
when functional the bots will search a
wide range of file sharing and video
streaming websites for scp-2030 and
remove any manifestations discovered
finding an isolating SCP 2030s point of
origin is considered a delta level
priority efforts to locate the studio
where scp-2030 is filmed our ongoing
description scp-2030 is an anomalous
phenomenon that manifests as a
television series the medium through
which scp-2030 manifests changes
depending on the most popular format
currently in use as of 2014
scp-2030 most commonly inserts itself
into automated DVD rental kiosks file
sharing websites and paid on-demand
video streaming services prior to 2012
scp-2030 commonly manifested as a DVD
set in video rental stores and as VHS
tapes prior to 2003 thus far no reliable
evidence that scp-2030 manifestations
took place prior to the year 1993 has
been discovered
however 38 seasons of programming are
known to exist implying that scp-2030
has been active to some degree since
1976 the series title typically appears
as laughs is fun although variations on
this name such as laugh his life for
laugh
laughs are not uncommon the series has
no corresponding box art it mimics art
from other television series often
causing viewers to select it mistaking
it for another program the show is a
hidden-camera comedy series showcasing
the candid responses of various people
to bizarre disturbing and often
anomalous situations episodes usually
run between 10 and 12 minutes and
feature introductory and closing
segments that bookend the hidden camera
footage no episode to date has had an
end credit role as CP 2031 is a
presumably human adult male that serves
as the show's host providing
introductory and closing commentary as
well as appearing to victims to reveal
that they are being filmed for a
television series scp-2030 one is
invariably shown wearing a royal blue
three-piece suit with black and white
wing tip shoes due to the way in which
scenes are filmed scp-2030 1 is only
seen from the neck down making
identification difficult it refers to
itself as laughy mclarson
individuals appearing on the show often
react to the events that they witness
with panic or distress but immediately
appear calmed upon the appearance of
scp-2030 1 this is true even when the
individual in question has sustained
significant bodily harm or witnessed a
particularly traumatic event
additionally most recorded individuals
seem to express some degree of
familiarity with a CP 2031 with some
claiming to be fans of the show research
into whether scp-2030 uses its
viewership as a victim selection pool is
ongoing episodes follow a particular
theme that each prank segment alludes to
scp-2030 1 introduces these themes at
the beginning of each episode in an
as-of-yet
unidentified film studio whilst standing
atop a bright yellow stage decorated
with oversized geometric shapes of
various colors episode themes may vary
from the mundane such as the beach pets
and candy to the strange and violent
such as mail fraud arson and terrorism
scp-2030 1 delivers a small speech at
the end of each program to close out the
show at the end of each episode the
camera pulls back and around scp-2030 1
stage to show the studio audience which
usually comprises the individuals
featured in the episode during this time
the words filmed in front of a studio
audience created in partnership with ywt
GTH ft are superimposed over the footage
in white text research into the
identities of the people featured in the
show's prank segments has revealed that
they are all persons who were officially
documented as having died or gone
missing in the year they appeared on the
program thorough investigations into the
depths of scp-2030 participants have
revealed a number of inconsistencies and
contradictions in matters concerning the
circumstances of the deaths
additionally exclamations of the
individual's remains have revealed that
all recorded participants bodies are
currently missing the general consensus
among researchers assigned to scp-2030
is that victims are likely to be
abducted after their use in the show
with their disappearances covered up
when possible however no concrete
evidence connecting the individuals
deaths with scp-2030
besides the show's footage has yet been
found
[Music]
addendum the following are examples of
pranks featured on the program season 24
2013 swelling individuals involved may
see Gershom and Kyle Parker killed by a
hit-and-run driver on September 18th
2000 scene description
an elderly woman sits on a park bench
feeding nearby pigeons with seed from a
bag
Gershom and parker a couple walked down
a park path and approached the woman
once the to come within approximately
1.5 metres of the elderly woman a swarm
of pigeons fly into the elderly woman's
mouth causing her stomach to become
severely engorged and quickly rupture
the couple expressed great distress at
the event until scp-2030 one emerges
from the elderly woman's open stomach
cavity at which point
Gershom and parker appear relieved
season 21 1997 episode theme Margaret
Thatcher individuals involved
Doris Carter died of ovarian cancer
February 24th 1997 scene description
miss Carter walks into her kitchen and
opens a cabinet door out of which falls
a large mass of flesh as Carter screams
mass grows and shapes itself into a
severely disproportional facsimile of
former Prime Minister of the United
Kingdom Margaret Thatcher with its head
twice as large as its torso Carter
rushes to leave the room but the
Thatcher creature leaps onto her before
she can escape it extends its tongue
into the woman's open mouth and Thatcher
faces of various sizes begin appearing
across Carter's skin the faces proceed
to recite Thatcher's April 1986 speech
on the bombing of Libya in perfect
unison scp-2030 one climbs out of a
nearby cupboard and points to the hidden
cameras miss Carter smiles the creatures
tongue extended down her throat season
13 1989 episode theme squirrels
individuals involved Melissa and Travis
England disappeared last seen made 12
1989 scene description miss England lies
in a bed next to a male figure
presumably mr. England a series of
high-pitched squeaking noises are heard
and mrs. England is awakened she tells
her husband to wake up but he does not
respond she places her hand on his
shoulder but quickly draws it back with
a shriek his skin begins to undulate as
though something is moving underneath a
multitude of squirrels that burst from
various places on his body quickly
filling the bed and crawling on to the
woman she rises to leave the room but as
CP 2031 walks in and turns on the light
he is accompanied by mr. England who has
been skinned from head to foot but gives
no indication of feeling
any discomfort all three Cheryl laughs
and the segment ends
jesus-fuckin'-christ season 13 1989
episode theme tracheotomies individuals
involved gary Turman lindsey terman and
their children died in a vehicular
accident on April 28th 1989 scene
description before sit around a dinner
table eating a meal mister Terman begins
coughing and gasping for air as if
choking as the others at the table begin
to panic a pair of slits appear on
Turman throat allowing him to breathe
these slits quickly become nostrils
which rapidly grow into a full nose
which in turn becomes an entire second
head identical to termined original this
second head then sprouts a neck of its
own and the entire process repeats this
continues until 18 necks and heads have
sprouted from the original at which
point scp-2030 1 steps out from
underneath the table everyone present
erupts into raucous laughter including
all 19 of mr. Sherman's heads
season 37 2013 episode theme cephalopods
individuals involved rebecca nash
surgeons unidentified died of
complications in child delivery on
november 2nd 2013 hospital records show
no evidence of anomalous activity during
birth scene description a team of
obstetricians perform a caesarean
section procedure on miss nash who was
in labor the team comment on the size of
the child's cranium and the amount of
hair present on it several minutes into
the procedure a doctor makes an
exclamation of surprise and drops an
instrument on the floor muffled
vocalizations can be heard in the
background the rest of the staff begin
to panic as the head emerges unassisted
from Nash causing her a great deal of
pain the child's head can be seen to
resemble that of American television
presenter Ryan Seacrest the child sings
row row row your boat in a female voice
as it continues to exit the mother as
more of its form emerges the child can
be seen to have the body of a fully
grown octopus octopus vulgaris once the
child fully exits Nash's body it
continues to sing as another head begins
to emerge three more children are
produced in total with the heads of
celebrities Jack Nicholson American film
actor Johnny Cash American
singer-songwriter and Martin Freeman
British film actor respectively all with
similar octopus bodies together the four
sing row row row your boat in a
four-part harmony scp-2030 one walks
into the room and the show's jingle
plays scp-2030 one points to the hidden
cameras in the room prompting the
obstetricians and Nash to begin laughing
the creatures on Nash's torso continued
to sing Nash then loses consciousness
presumably from blood loss
the following is a recording of a
typical speech delivered by scp-2030 one
during one of the show's closing
segments season 32 2008 episode theme
printers playing log now what a ride hey
folks we've seen printers that eat
printers that print and everything in
between makes you appreciate the old
clunker you have back in the office
doesn't know printers may not always
work when you want or need them to but
they sure make for some excellent comedy
and that's what we're about comedy we're
here to make you laugh
we hope you laugh thank you for laughing
with us that's what we're about here
doesn't it folks come laugh with us
again next time and remember laugh is
fun good night and laugh and laugh just
laugh we love the make laugh make more
for laughter so as to for laugh laugh
with us laugh with us laugh with us
laugh with us laugh with us laugh with
us
laugh laugh laugh and let us earn
note video cuts off abruptly and a black
screen is displayed for 30 seconds
laughter and soft wet noises can be
heard in the background before the
program ends
you know I gotta confess I left pretty
hard at the transcription of that
squirrel tape I'm going to hell for that
one anyway I think that about does it
for today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed goodbye I would like to give a
special thank you to slump god Justin
day John Porter fluffy Pierce M Hamlin
white crew beware 600 my archive curator
neck tie verbal Kody tench cheese whip
dips McGee and oblong dish boy if you
would like a special thank you at the
end of each of my videos on some other
cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you